I am an idiot so I thought this game
couldn't get any funnier and someone
told me to turn on the bobblehead option
so I'm gonna let him go I'm just gonna
let him go and do his thing
Tori's not gonna go anywhere you son of
a [ __ ] you handsome son of a [ __ ] you
that is absolutely ridiculous are you
even going what is the point of where's
my head go what happened to me oh you
look very happy about your situation
there buddy all right take Wow really be
kidding me how could I be mad at you and
stop giving me that look hi buddy how
you doing you don't feel so good - yeah
I really can't handle this oh god it is
sorry goddamn pickles
where did I go what happened to me
policy flying cars it's coming I swear
why is this so funny to see my face
being tossed around like that man hi
buddy how are you all right Oh God what
happened to you
tell me who hurt you like this who did
this to you hustlin and we'll stop I
feel a more personal connection now
don't get buddy of me yet
oh hello there nice Oh his leg your foot
there are you happy to see me hello
there baby
did something happened to you are you
just so sexy right now
we haze her friend that's a good look a
little worried oh no he's fine
there's the happiness areas I'm like
he's like you like what you see baby
that's well and build a plane wait oh no
there was more I'm sorry oh you're okay
it's gonna be hot right look at that
smile
did anyone doubt that smile
I can't it'll fit oh good for you
this is by far by far the silliest thing
I have ever done in my life
this is regard dam dick Ulis but it is
so amazing I love it so much
am I gonna be okay doctor this level is
literally called wall of train honestly
oh god there goes my head where oh where
could my face have gone I didn't see it
oh oh is that it oh is that it
hey buddy you look good oh yeah my guys
ready to go my gosh buddy go waiting my
god go what happened buddy are you okay
all right now don't do whatever the hell
happened before again me oh where did my
face go no no no little buddy I found
him I don't know where he's going but I
found him come on baby you can make it
okay maybe not oh you can make it okay
maybe not
ready for the ride of your life buddy
where'd you go I wonder what will happen
now
but it still looks happy if slightly
confused let's see what you can do oh
you missed the track you didn't mind me
when I was a kid I used to get stuck in
those things all the time
oh me that's very wrong I think you just
severed your crotch you ready for a fun
ride oh my god oh what's going on with
your arms looking good buddy Oh looking
good you're gonna make it yeah ah dude
you left your ass
twitching in that bird oh hi I swear the
stupidest things make me laugh no matter
what the stupidest [ __ ] but god damn it
I love it this is hilarious alright
alright guys that was more turbo
dismount with my face and holy crap that
was absolutely amazing
I don't know why I found it so funny but
if you guys enjoyed it and you want to
see more turbo dismount especially if
you want to see it with my face on there
hello
by leaving a like down below thank you
all so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video